I would like to inform you that by way of
exception the explanations of vote
are postponed to tomorrow I remind you that the
explanations of vote can
also be submitted in writing colleagues and
colleagues pursuant to article 125 of the
regulation the parliament elects and
rejects the commission by a majority
of votes  cast by roll call
after the vote I will announce the results
of the votes if the commission receives a
majority of the votes cast I will sign the
transmission letter announcing
the approval of the parliament I
will deliver it to the chairman of the
commission and I will inform the council
on this basis the council  European Commission
will officially appoint the commission
the election of the commission by roll call
the vote is open
all voted
the vote is closed approved four
161 votes in favor 157 against and 89
abstentions
[Applause]
first
before signing
[Applause]
chairman takes to  place before
signing the at  of the appointment
I would like